Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Yo, Yo,
what's good?
Yo
brief.
Hey,
hey
dancing or Brandon like popular songs.
This are fun. And I was like, hey.
And actually it looks good
and it looks Kinda cool.
So I just kept doing that
and then it started blowing
up and I just went with it.
It's like,
why not?
Like if you're 1415 and you're just
starting to get a lot of followers on
Instagram as not something you just said.
No worries.
My name is Russell,
but people know me as backpack kid.
I'm 16 years old and I
am a content creator.
So I'm from Atlanta,
Georgia and I'm really just
a normal teenage kid and I
just started doing videos
on the Internet and these blew up.
You ain't on the list.
Got To do better.
What did they think? They thought
I was just doing me having fun.
So they just went along with it.
They let me travel with a manager.
Not a lot of parents would do that.
Okay.
How many?
I would say maybe two.
Almost three.
So a lot has happened in the past
two to three years. Do you invent?
Yes.
Most celebrities that you can think
of have probably done the dance before
and then I went on
SNL with Katy Perry and that's when it
really, really, really popped off. Wait,
you said what?
I can do that
now before noon on a Monday.
Okay. Okay. Okay,
and what are you about to post a
me philosophy with bronze burner.
Yeah. I'll tell you why.
Heavyweight champion. Yeah. Nice.
All right.
Yes.
Cool.
And then also a part right here and
then like a design on this side.
It's fun traveling and meeting New People.
I like attention.
Yeah, I get it. I get a lot of that now.
Bella Bella backpack kit. Here
you are. No one's going on. Yeah,
the people around me have definitely
changed. They all want to be my friend now
or is that weird? It's not my
problem. It's their problem,
not mine. There's still a
lot of hair on my forehead.
He was really good. This
one, it was really good.
Can we take the Chili off regularly?
I'll take a root beer float.
You feel like you've changed
through this process? Not really.
I still act the same way. How, how I
usually like act before all this happened,
we're all star just posted me
teaching Deontay wilder how to floss.
Like if the backpack gets fell off
at the most liked comment right now.
Coordination skills,
not on point. Same Old,
same old check my story.
Oh my God, it's insane.
Hey people that just try to
advertise themselves on my page
overall.
Yes,
I do think social media is a good thing
because it's a way for people to keep
social. Oh yeah, there's
definitely cyber bullying.
So I read my comments all the
time and really a main one.
No care.
I run it back one more time.
We have the same to drip
on boat coming soon.
Yes. I'm dropping a project
this year. You African, uh,
hopefully pop off my music career.
I tried to have my own style.
Like you don't want to anybody else's
rob flow like any old school rappers.
Um, like I know of Tupac and Biggie.
I don't really listen to them though,
but I do respect that.
Like they are legends.
We are off to Steve.
I label to see what's up with a single
that we're trying to drive with them.
So I remember in these meetings like when
we talked about the kid stuff that we
talked about like four
or how about you do?
I'm a talker and I'm the
face of the operation.
Hello.
Nice to meet you too.
In my opinion is not really
anything hard about it.
I guess just like hard work
and a few days of little sleep,
but that's just like work. You work a
lot though. Yeah, for a 16 year old,
but it's fun work.
Do you ever feel tired?
Feeling tired is boring?
I can just imagine doing a new
segment right here. Hey guys,
my name is bag pack kit and welcome to
backpack kid news and weather and today's
recent stories, backpack is
dropped. Paid any fee this year.
Amazing
backdrop.
This is a nice view.
If you think of backpack kid,
you think of a guy who created a floss
and does silly dances on his Instagram.
But I'm trying to get credibility as a
rapper because being a rapper it looks
like a lot of fun and I want to use that
opportunity to do good in the world.
Right.
There's a huge truck coming your way.
It's definitely a good experience
for a 16 year old then.
Not a lot of them experienced.
Like I know that most teenagers don't
go through the life that I go through,
but I feel like that this
life that I live is normal.
So normal.
It's not normal.
No, I wouldn't say it's normal.
It's normal to me. Yeah.
But it's not normal to everybody else.
I'm in 11th grade,
so I have this year to finish and the
next year and then I'm done with high
school and then I have my whole life
ahead of me to do whatever I need to do
actually.
And my friends might go to college,
so I don't know what I'm
going to do about that. So
it's pretty unlikely at this at this
moment, because I already have a career.
I just gotta stay poppy to not need
to college. If I do need colleagues,
that means that like I've completely
fallen off and I'm not making any more
money,
I would have died.
Right.
Okay. Yeah, that was Frederick
and Jayden and Jordan.
My friends and family,
they're definitely important for keeping
me sane through this whole process.
They just treated me the same way.
They said nothing in particular.
I liked that though.
I like attention. I was always the
class clown and the good ole elementary,
middle school days.
Love being loud and making a scene.
Yes.
Look both ways.
Yeah.
For the rest of the tonight I'm going
to see the premiere or wreck it.
Ralph breaks the Internet
in the background.
Yeah.
I'm trying to get into fanny packs.
So these are all the people
that have broken the Internet.
I've seen his name's Skye.
Me or I saw the video with,
um,
what's the name again? Jantek. Okay,
so the video would Deontay wilder,
97 k views and then stories,
16 k views, 11 k views, 10 k you
think eight views and yeah, that's it.
Where do you get your sense of competence?
Um,
okay.
I guess this, this is how I
am, like my persona is myself,
so I got to do with the myself.
Don't pay attention when everybody
thinks of you and just do you.
That's the best way to do it.
No problem.
Oh,
do you feel like you've
achieved your dream?
And I have my whole life ahead
of me to achieve even Lord.
Okay.
Hey, I was good backpack. Katie here.
Big things that you believe Ravena
a in the life of a backpack kid,
but I got to catch his movie premiere.
Bye.
Yes. Is that okay? You show up.
Where do you want to go? Anywhere.
Do you get to price all
the time? Yeah. Sorry.
You're good. You're good. You want to go.